over the weekend Los Angeles experienced
a massive heat wave did you know that
I'm sure you did yeah yeah some people
were so desperate for air conditioning
they actually went to see the new
Transformers movie people kind of
thought I was being me and then they
thought
oh no that movie really saw Nicolas of
course everyone else is the big story at
this weekend's g20 summit President
Trump and Vladimir Putin had a private
two-and-a-half hour meeting two and a
half hour meeting yeah yeah probably not
a good sign that it ended with Putin
handing Trump a single red rose
they were in hot tubs together President
Trump is being criticized now because he
allowed his daughter Ivanka to sit in
for him at the g20 summit
yeah Ivanka sat in for him at the g20
summit at a press conference today the
White House's press Secretary's
eight-year-old daughter said it's no big
deal
that's my kid licking a lolly yeah I
don't know I hate to play around on
Saturday
speaking of President Trump on Saturday
President Trump had back-to-back
meetings with the leaders of China and
then Japan yep it was an awkward moment
when Trump asked the leader of Japan hey
didn't I just meet with you what's the
story here
[Applause]
some good news in Iraq Isis is on the
verge of total defeat yeah you can tell
you can tell Isis is pretty much on the
way out cuz they've already been booked
to appear on next season's Dancing with
the Stars oh wow that's tough about Isis
some tech experts this was in the news
some tech experts in Silicon Valley now
believe that a robot would make a better
president than a human that's what
they're saying yeah I don't know about
you but at this point I would vote for
president Roomba I really
you love that if they played hail to the
chief and a room but just came in I've
got a little dirt off the floor and you
be like he's getting things done all
right
you